[Music]
from the visionary director behind that
movie where amy adams talks to tentacles
you comes a critically acclaimed sequel
that dares to ask provocative questions
like what is a soul what is the nature
of love and hey where's everybody going
hello we got Gosling here you guys like
Gosling right Blade Runner
20:49 for 40 years
audiences have been astonished by the
prescience of 1982's Blade Runner which
may have predicted a future where the
Soviet Union survived flat screens were
never invented and wars were fought by
intelligent androids but did predict a
world where every sci-fi movie and TV
show was a cerebral ponderous mine's
about artificial intelligence that so
weigh down with importance all the
characters talk at half-speed
makes one feel desire so what you saw
didn't happen many is that I dream of
cheese do mind
unannounced visits new police return to
the world of Blade Runner 30 years later
a grim dystopia where replicas are still
hunted down by the LAPD a reboot
friendly great blackout has wiped out
any information that could potentially
move the plot forward pre blackout and
it's gonna be tough and meet Kay a new
kind of replicant that can't ever go
rogue and turn on his masters we don't
run any older models - until he totally
goes rogue and turns on his masters with
you ryan gosling disappears into a
brilliant performance where he says very
little you have anything more to say
barely emotes they'll be coming after me
soon
do you remember anything you have any
memories from before you look lonely and
spends most of the film by himself just
kind of wandering around
[Music]
wait has every Ryan Gosling character in
the last decade been a replicant this
explains so much beer there you go beat
him up for me guy huh original star
Harrison Ford returns as Rick Deckard
the maybe replicant Blade Runner who
like a true deadbeat dad abandoned his
child and ran away to live in Vegas
he'll take longer to show up in the
movie than he would in a celebrity
charity event then give his most lively
and energetic performance of the decade
so he's at about a five five and a half
he'll face off against cruel
technologist Jared Leto who finally got
a chance to show up in a sequel plus
he'll be reunited with his true love
Rachel and oh wow yikes that is well but
there are lots of other women characters
in the movie it's not like they're all
badasses or sex objects who get killed
to move the story along like Robin
Wright as badass lieutenant Josh II
killed okay well there's love the badass
evil replicant just determined to clean
okay there's joy an artificially
intelligent hologram program to please
men and then dies all right how about
Mariette she's a prostitute oh you don't
even smile but she lives she makes it
through the movie I think you know I had
to go the bathroom like twice oh and I
really don't know
so finally clear out some time for this
epic beautifully realized second chapter
- one of the most influential sci-fi
stories of all time that delivered the
original storytelling audiences demanded
as an alternative to interchangeable
blockbusters then didn't show up to
support it at all there's your branch no
one because this movie isn't just about
mindless robot fistfights
it's a high-minded meditation on the
ethics and reasoning behind robot
fistfights okay
yeah punch that robot we'll figure out
later if it has a soul
starring Special K living alone solo D
girls thirty Seconds to Mars but really
that's how long it takes in the future
princess Buttercup the terminate tricks
dave bautista
and my little pony hardship is tragic
buds baby you know it's really too bad
that this movie didn't do better
Dylan knew probably won't get another
shot of reinventing another classic
sci-fi property huh it'll probably be
smaller scale to gauge audience interest
at first are these guys lawyering money
for the cartel or something peons
assemble I'm sorry
your answer has to be in the form of a
question I'm a dwarf and I'm digging a
hole diggy diggy hole I'm digging a hole
he's not a dude you're a dude this is a
man I must buy a girl in the Marvel
world